à vos amis ha oui vous diront les
secrets de la vie si tous kankan est
astucieux belle
c'est le plus sérieux
les cas ça me dit à jouer il suffit de
vouloir devenir amis
oui
[Musique]
fabrice oui bonjour tout le monde
bonjour à tous alors qu'est ce que tu me
dis rien ah bon ben alors on reste comme
ça oui on ne bouge plus on ne bouge plus
non on bouge plus pendant un quart
d'heure au non ce serait trop sa serai
ton ballon commence le jeu on fait le
jeu ea store le jeu graphique plutôt
quelques tôles et dit mais je vais mal
dit parce que j'ai déraillé joie immense
le jeu géographique géographie voilà
c'est un pays aujourd'hui encore oui il
faut le deviner et avec quoi on le
devine
grâce à quoi grâce à sur l'intelligence
oui non mais grâce à sa carte
géographique la ville aux cent drapeaux
deuxième élément est enfin bon jour dans
la langue du pays
le troisième élément voilà j'y vais
bazire est fait
voici la carte du pays où l'alors
d'amorcer d'amour soit ou non est un
gros morceau
je ne le traverse pas en deux jours je
ne pense pas voici le drapeau du pays
bon bah ça c'est facile a pourri rouge
et puis les petites choses là c'est
jaune oui c'est assez facile oui ça
c'est falloir peut-être ce qu'on ne sait
pas oui c'est les commandites aux bons
jours dans ce pays
un jour bonjour bonjour ah oui brasse
voutier drass vautier 13 août et à ses
strass voutier oui enfin et on voit que
c'est oui c'est david danis lhadji
badiane
enfin on est en train de commettre une
toute petite erreur parce que si tu veux
ça c'est la langue la plus parlée dans
ce pays mis à d'autres langues faut pas
l'oublier c'est important
tapie qui composait de plusieurs langues
plusieurs peuples oui oui oui c'est très
important vous l'avez reconnu c'est le
plus grand pays du monde en surface
c'est l'urss l'urss avec beaucoup de
république dont la russie et dont la
langue russe stress voutier d'asie
damien convient de parler
la capitale est ici c'est moscou le
drapeau vous le connaissez et je vous
rappelle que c'est en étant dû en
superficie le plus grand pays du monde
voit les animaux russes comment pourrais
je dire eh bah maintenant fabrice va
dans le jardin moi je vais faire le jeu
avec sa mousse et bien je ne fais pas
parce que je ne parle pas russe
elle va tuer en ignorant a fait
attention à ce que tu dis que je vais me
fâcher tu sors à la dore top 10 andy
murray chose à voir ça je me rends chez
moi tiens oui j'avais 20 voilà voilà
j'appelle fabrice fabrice j'ai vraiment
pas pourquoi tu sors puisque tu reviens
aussi tôt qu'est ce qui te suivent à
fait je vais prendre l'air et qu'est ce
que tu fais exactement gratter d'or je
me promène bon alors assieds toi c'est
le point commun tous les trois vous
représenter quelque chose et je veux
savoir quel est le point qui vous unit
le moins comme un voile va être bon et
bien si je commence comme d'habitude
c'est à toi de jouer tout cas encore bon
et bien
1 je ne suis pas n'importe quoi comme ça
je l'avais remarqué
oui non je t'en prie je ne passe pas
facilement inaperçu c'est vrai je suis
grand solide ce que je représente a tu
vois pas ce que bonnie tout frais là et
on me voit de loin
en général on me voit dans des endroits
où il ya une grande fête à célébrer oui
grande victoire un trio tu vois alors
dans ces cas-là on organise des défilés
avec musique uniforme et la foule
applaudit
massés le long des avenues qui
m'entourent c'est pour moi c'est un
régal on trouve d'ailleurs dans beaucoup
de pays on ne trouve dans plusieurs
villes de france et naturellement à
paris et j'ai pris énormément
photographier visiter escalader et c'est
pas mal je ne suis pas la tour eiffel
alors qui suis-je
oui que celui juil oui voilà qui se fit
je te le demande un véritable
éblouissement
un enchantement quand vous voyez
apparaître vous possédez cris
d'admiration et vous avez bien raison ma
forme et couleur tout en moi est
admirable il faut bien le dire je suis
assez rare je me montre ohkoshi cela me
fait plaisir et la plupart du temps je
ne reste pas très longtemps devant vous
je m'efface je m'évanouis sans que vous
puissiez rien faire pour me retenir pour
moi tout est une question de ciel il me
faut un peu de nuages et soleil et
quelques gouttes de pluie pour être
vraiment bien je suis ébloui
bon moi je crois que j'ai une bonne idée
mais enfin je préfère attendre la
version 2 pouces moussu pour être sûr de
moi bon manama - atari go permet lui
permet laisse parler les grandes
périodes alors ben moi je vais dire je
suis quelque chose qui est utilisé par
les chasseurs
et attention pas par les chasseurs
d'aujourd'hui non ceux qui viennent me
piétiner la m'écraser avec l'ordre aux
chaussures
ah si tu voyais dans quel état je fais
le dimanche soir cette offre affreux
avenant dont je veux parler des
chasseurs il ya bien longtemps que je
n'ai pas connu d'ailleurs ses chats sont
là mais mon grand père oui mon grand
père m'a souvent parlé
alors pour être chasseur à cette époque
là il fallait être rapide et rudement
adroit mais on n'y avait pas de fusil
papa de carabine
on sursaute et pas toutes les deux
minutes comme de nos jours
non remarquons bien que à notre époque
et encore des gens qui se servent de moi
oui mais c'est pas c'est pas pour
chasser non c'est simplement pour
prouver leur adresse riz est une sorte
de sport
ac c'est très joli à voir avec eux quand
ils font voler leurs projectiles vers le
ciel c'est très jeune très très joli
alors je suppose que vous avez tous
deviné lorsque tout cas encore nous a
parlé de triomphe où tout à l'heure dans
les villes
vous avez sûrement pensé à l'arc de
triomphe
lorsque bell bell nous a parlé
longuement de saboter tout ça pourrait
penser à la nacelle et enfin pouces
motion à l'instant il s'intéressait à
l'arc au tir à l'arc
voilà et bien alors je vous laisse oui
je vais préparer quelque chose très très
chouette pas trop difficile à roko mais
j'aime bien voir quand tu sèches un
petit poucet oui oui c'est à nouveau du
bonhomme je suis prêt et là j'ai un mot
assez difficile pour toile majoritaire à
oui je t'ai gratter j'espère que je vais
pouvoir te coller était un j'espère
toujours mais avec toi c'est difficile
ah oui c'est très difficile parce que
difficile surtout c'est de reconnaître
les mots mais lorsque tu les écrits
alors malheureusement on pour repousse
me su nous avons tous perdu l'espoir que
tu puisse un jour écrire correctement ça
dépend ça dépendra l'orthographe et toi
enfin alors cette semaine j'ai un mot
assez long oui oui oui un mot en douze
lettres 12 lettres
ça commence par quoi et bien ça commence
par un c encore mais décidément tu
adores le raja d'or laissait alors après
je voulais dit ray voilà exactement
comme d'habitude 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 et
ensuite alors je servais roumanie la
dernière lettre un oui ça aussi j'ai
remarqué que tu aimais bien que ça se
termine alors c'est une fleur
non non c'est pas une c'est une plante
ce n'est pas une plante c'est un arbre
c'est pas un arbre c'est un animal qui
est un animal c'est un gros animal non
non non non c'est un petit petit petit
animal est un petit animal de qui
vie en france oui en europe oh oui oui
il y en a partout y en a partout ils
sont très mignons c'est pas une couleur
oh oui ça c'est vrai non non non non
c'est bleus n'ont plus ces blancs non
plus c'est rouge oui c'est rouge fait
route à éveiller rouge jaune violet très
bas cette année une hotte est la
troisième la troisième l'aide c'est un
cul à cul oui mais un cul oui voila je
vais encore t d un petit peu ce qu'il
veut il ya des petits points noirs
elle est rouge avec des petits points
noirs et on dit que des fois elle porte
bonheur elle est rouge des petits points
noirs album bona oui ça avec un cod bury
et un qi syrie enfin tout quand grand
bain diwaniya je rêve ou quoi
non c'était ce à quoi ils pensent du ce
à quoi ils parlent
bah oui je suis sûr qu'il s'agit d'une
coccinelle sacrément bat à trouver comme
ci n'est pas quoi seigneur m'a redonné
lui mais pardonnez lui la façon il écrit
coccinelle avait langue qu ici juan
barazi annuel je vais le pouvoir et je
vais encore fait une faute et pelles
pouvoir coccyx et au quetzsat-1 n e
alors pour ta gouverne et spa regarde
comment on écrit coccinelle co2 c'est ya
jamais eu de cul là dedans on le sait la
coque inc
coke ce n'est pas un coq et au coccyx
comme une coquille ou coccyx a tant aidé
à y avoir deux n ose pas de bêtises
parce que tu menant à l'oeil à deux
c'est le renard mais les deux cessons là
un bon coccinelle ses deux ailes je ne
sais même pu écrire à cause de diana
faute m'embrouille complètement j'avais
de la route
il y à un soleil mais il y à 2 c
c'est là un bois la jante alu gaza mais
oui c'est charles est bas alors c'est
parfait tunnel mais oui ben moi je suis
fatigué tu sait tous que ça s'écrivait
comme coop mois comme le dit mais est-ce
que tu connais la nourriture préférée
des coccinelles toi ah bah voilà bah je
suis bien content mais je vais te
l'apprendre ce sont les pucerons et les
débords elle les extermine et c'est pour
ça que quand on fait des élevages de
coccinelles et ben on en fait beaucoup
on fait beaucoup d'élevages de
coccinelles et on en vend aux jardiniers
ah oui mais quand ils ont trop de
pucerons dans leur jardin
voilà savoir eh oui et oui je suis bien
content de l'avoir appris belle gueule
oui je t'attends c'est moi plaisir
belles belles belles belles fais moi
plaisir explique tout le nom en bas
c'est passé nous l'expliquent pas du
tout non parce que tous les enfants
savent très bien que chaque fois qu'il
ya une note de musique dans les mots que
je dis je remplace ses notes de musique
pas mais moi je mets la note sont la
porte exactement
donc je voudrais faire une confidence
oui je te parle souvent de mes idées de
grandeur de mes rêves de 8 du multi 2
mai 6 et j'ai aussi des goûts très
simple j'aime bien les voyages oui c'est
vrai mais je suis très content aussi de
booster à paris au bon de rester à paris
oui c'est aussi riche que le monde
entier remonter le boulevard ça shell
c'est bon 6 voilà jusqu'au luxembourg
et si on n'aime pas le luxembourg on va
au
chaumont à c'est utile aux
buttes-chaumont fils à l'ancienne
appellation de dos ira aux
buttes-chaumont tout là-haut et du lao
découvre tout la grande tour elle aurait
ont causé ont causé des sims à la figure
et la tour un courriel ou apple donc
voilà scène qui se promènent
paresseusement le long de l'ill de la
paix n'est l'île de la tva dans la cité
c'est les péniches qui passent le pont
le firino solférino bien sûr seul
j'aime aussi regarder le sacré coeur le
simple hobby pas terrible ça si oui oui
c'est le sacré coeur il y avait trouvé
des arrêts et le même bois des invalides
il a trouvé le petit tas le des
invalides hui à le dos on ne souffle pas
rapide mais alors rien dire alors elles
n'ont rien du tout y est le dos me gêne
même remaniée au plus tôt me balader dg
voilà là il y a un petit marché que
j'adore c'est le petit marché de pas
aussi dit cas ci n'est pas sûr qu'en
dépit petiteau vous voyez ferlicot sion
aussi je vais chercher des piétons
bercon sion mine avec un cabas je vais
faire mes fonctions je dernier tu vas
chez l'épicier tu fais les conventions
article je n'entends rien alors vous
dérange peut-être assez vite et nous
dérange parce que de chanter we had
salla allah voilà je voulais copé veut
faire autre chose toi rapide aux
surveillants fabrice te plaît alors
toujours la pluie chez lui à les quatre
amis sont déjà pourquoi pas aux amis les
quatre ça lit vous diront que secrète de
la vie s'est désisté et rzeszow fait des
choses mais comme juni pas de mine war
il faudra faire attention les gars ça me
sont contents pas descendre et u10 les
caps a mis sont heureux car ils aiment
la vie
oui
moi
je visionne les gars vous avez à jouer
aujourd'hui il suffit de vouloir devenir
un avis il s'est fait de vouloir devenir
amis
c'est pourquoi est ce qu il veut
retourner dans l'appareil oui oui si on
avait lu rapide au dessus aurait pu mais
c'était amusant ou bien marché c'est ça
que tu vois pas pourquoi la pelle râteau